welcome back to Sky News tonight now we
are staying with the unrest in China
that is without precedent in recent
years certainly for 33 years and
throughout the day we've been asking you
to send in your questions about what is
going on there and why and what it could
mean for global stability so we're going
to go through some of them now we've had
plenty of them with me is our
International Affairs editor Dominic
wagorn Zhang a Chinese writer and
journalist who participated in those
Tiananmen Square protests back in 1989
and Francis fukuyama the political
scientist and writer very good to get
you all here as I say we've got a lot of
questions to get through so let's
approach them our first question is from
Matthew who asked quite simply and
people want to know this because it's
always hard to get accurate information
out of China isn't it how widespread are
these protests legia
I think it was quite a widespread I
would say probably something like a
dozen cities and including in general in
central China where hundreds of iPhone
Factory workers went to straight to
protest and even they torn down the
barricade and then we saw
um protests broke out in murugi in
northwest of xinjiang Province
triggered by a fire and then we that
spread to Shanghai Nanjing Chengdu Ching
Hai quite a quite a lot of cities
yeah and Dominic what are you hearing
from journalistic sources uh yeah so
that's the surprising thing about this
is that it is it has been so widespread
because we've seen protests in China
over the years they do happen on
Mainland China they tend to be small
they tend to be pretty localized and
they are easily dealt with because of
that they're generally about very
specific grievances what's unexpected
about these and what makes them really
significant is they are widespread they
all sort of blew up out of out of
nowhere in on in these cities across
China which seem to suggest a certain
amount of national coordination although
it does seem to be spontaneous and
they're all about one thing which is
this national uh resentment about the
zero covids policy so for all those
reasons they are a huge challenge to you
know again Chinese party yeah I will try
to say I just really agree with you so
since 1989 there have been quite a lot
of uh uh protests but typically for
example Farmers went to protests like
Wukong in 2012 and protests against the
land grab or Factory workers again
Foxconn the workers demanded a better
pay and there are also occasional
protests against environmental issues
but those tend to be Regional tend to be
economic driven not political driven so
things like this I I would say I don't
think it's kind of one person organize
it it's spontaneous and happened in
multiple cities and all against one
issue and against the government it's a
real what's been happening is really
extraordinary okay well let's get more
into the the causes and the reason and
uh Professor for Kiama you take our next
question which is developing on what
we've just heard in the studio and very
good evening to you thank you for
joining us it's from Sylvester who asked
quite simply what is the reason for
these protests I suppose he really means
beyond that does it go beyond the zero
covered policies
well I think the zero covet policies by
themselves would provoke protests and
virtually any other country where they
were done in the kind of draconian way
that the Chinese government has been
doing it I mean uh there's been a recent
outbreak of covid even after the 20th
party Congress and as much as a quarter
of the country is under a lockdown and
when they go into a lockdown they're
serious about it you can't go out of
your apartment building uh you know the
lockdowns last for weeks at a time you
can't visit your relatives your children
there's all sorts of issues about
getting medicines and so forth and so
covet by itself I think uh is plenty bad
I mean the policy is plenty bad enough
to explain why after this length of time
people are fed up with it the other
problem is that there doesn't seem to be
any way out of this uh the government
doesn't seem to be interested in letting
up in a way it can't let up because
people are not vaccinated and they
really do worry about the disease
getting out and you know the frequency
of the lockdowns has been increasing
over time rather than decreasing and
when people saw the way that fans could
interact at the World Cup I think it
drove home to them how terrible their
own situation was
just on that issue of lockdowns did
people in China initially they did
didn't they just go along with it as in
countries around the world in our very
own country people people accepted the
lockdown this is a very interesting I
just recently wrote an article to look
at how the covert policy changed
people's perception and their trust and
faced in the government I would say
until about one year ago most vast
majority of Chinese accepted and they
saw they believed that the Chinese
government behaved very
um quickly and the situation under
control they accepted that but then they
you know we saw in Shanghai they had
this prolonged lockdown and it's you
know and then the rest Awards returned
to normal and China still have to endure
this excessive lockdown and one thing is
that I would want to point out is that
the local officials they have been
competing meaning coming out excessive
ways to to show their loyalty to Xi
Jinping for example what finding new
ways to impose lockouts yes for example
in xiamen they even test the fish crumbs
squids and this is ridiculous and just
before the party Congress in Two Cities
ancient Central China's Ashanti province
they went to lockdown there was not even
a single case so they just want to make
sure imagine we got to cats and minking
um domini wanted to say
yeah I mean I think it's a sign of yeah
as as Legion was saying that each party
secretary had to kind of out stuff the
next one didn't he to to show off his
his anti-cover credentials uh to Beijing
and as as you were saying there's
there's now this sense of well as
Professor fukion was saying there's a
sense of where do we go from here the
government doesn't seem to have a way
out of this and there's a real sense I
think amongst the Chinese that the rest
of the world is leaving them behind and
the big case in point is what they've
been seeing on their television screen
so the World Cup so the World Cup
they're seeing these crowds in football
stadiums without masks sitting amongst
each other apparently you know not not
fearful of catching the virus and
actually Chinese TV has been censoring
it uh giving it a bit of delay and then
replacing the crowd shots with close-ups
of referees and players so if you're if
you're in Shanghai or zhongju or someone
you've been stuck at home and you've
been told this is for your own good and
Trust the government we've got it don't
worry we've got your backs we have a
world-beating solution to this if you're
then seeing what's going on in Qatar
then then the penny is dropping that
this is
let's get into some more of the Polish
because one here from Francis at this
point
um and this is a question from our
viewer called Jacob uh asking this are
the protests then as we look into the
politics of it specifically against Xi
Jinping or against more broadly the
Communist Party rule of the country are
they are they focused on the leader or
more on the system
well I'm not sure that you can
distinguish between the two uh one of
the things that Xi Jinping has done
since he came to power in 2013 is
replaced what had been a collective
leadership system uh with basically one
one-man rule uh I think that you know
before 2013 you need to get consensus
within the standing committee of the
polit bureau to make a decision uh today
I don't think there's a single other
member of that very small seven-member
group that could stand up against Xi
Jinping and say look this is a crazy
policy we've got to relax it and so it's
both a product of the way that the
Communist party has evolved over the
period that Xi Jinping has been in power
and it's about the fact that you know
you've got a policy that is very closely
identified with Xi Jinping you know with
this one individual and I think it makes
it very difficult for him to back down
and admit that he was wrong about this
after having invested so much of his own
prestige in in you know zero covid
alternating uh president this then uh
follows directly into our next question
from Luke asking is this the most
significant protest in China since
Tiananmen Square we've been mentioning
that in our introduction and what
response can we expect therefore from Xi
Jinping and the CCP in the hours days
and weeks ahead now of course Lee jar
you were involved in the Tiananmen
protests did you see parallels coming in
terms of the the Crackdown the treatment
of the protesters yes I do I mean and I
in 1989 you know
um that was uh started by student in
Beijing but grew to be a national uh
movement I was dealing that was factory
worker in Nanjing I organized a large
protest among Factory workers and at
that time we I remember we were seeing
the national anthem the one line
particularly rise up rise up Rose do not
want to be slave which is being chanting
recently yeah so I I yes I do and in
terms of the Crackdown because you know
we all remember those Dreadful pictures
you know what we could see of the
Crackdown in Tiananmen Square do you
think that that may be a route that Xi
Jinping goes down
um it's I think it can go both ways
um
um he's a um Crackdown or he probably in
the media future we'll see come crack
down but he may back down a little bit
he I think that's up to him and and
somehow relax the control say we have
done really well now we or at least
provide some timeline for the moment
it's open-ended and people just doesn't
have hope I think this is very important
anyway if I'm if I can talk to Xi
Jinping I want him to remember one thing
we have a Chinese saying which says
people are like water and the ruler
Abode people can carry a boat can also
overtang it I hope he will remember that
very good what do you think of of that
uh Francis figure I mean what what can
we expect from XI Jin Bing and the CCB
in the hours days and weeks ahead in
terms of response to these protests
well uh he's really in a tough spot
right now uh normally you'd say well
just relax the the quarantines but the
problem is that China has a very low
rate of vaccination they've not been
willing to accept foreign vaccines like
moderna or Pfizer that would actually be
effective for nationalistic reasons uh
and so
um their own vaccines don't work very
well and therefore there's a large
number of elderly Chinese that are not
vaccinated and so if they do relax the
policy you're likely to I mean they've
already had this
gigantic spike in covid cases just in
the past week and if they really do
relax the uh the quarantine that's going
to get much much larger you could get
into a situation where they're going to
look like Europe or the United States in
the first year of covid you know where
you're getting uh thousands and
thousands of deaths from covid and so
you know going that past doesn't look
very promising for him but on the other
hand
having everybody just continue to be
locked down with no end in sight also
doesn't seem to be supportable so I'm
I'm really not sure if I were in his
position what I would do at this point
that said Dominic what do you think I
mean Jeff addresses this as well we're
on to this charity as well just this
question uh are these protests likely to
see a violent Crackdown as we saw in
Tiananmen school yeah I think it's like
a pressure cooker cooker either he puts
the lid on and tries to tighten it and
risks it exploding and risks more unrest
happening and there's a real risk of
that I think because there is so much
anger and frustration about this zero
covered lockdown policy or he releases
it a bit and then everyone gets burned
because his Professor the professor was
saying there that there's just because
they've been success successful at
controlling the virus there hasn't but
they haven't built up this National
immunity to it there's not been the
take-up for the for the vaccine and
their vaccines haven't been as effective
as Western vaccines so Xi Jinping would
have to lose face to import more
vaccines he would have to also say that
policy so far hasn't been hasn't really
worked and The crucial thing is is
getting the elderly to get vaccinated
um and the figures I've seen as you
could see because they also have very
few intensive care beds compared to the
West you could see between two and five
million Chinese dying many of them
elderly and in a country where the
elderly because of its Confucian past
and it's for cultural reasons the
elderly are very much revered and
respected and obviously venerated to
have that many people dying of that kind
of you know in that kind of demographic
it would be politically disastrous for
Xi Jinping so he has a very difficult
decision to make it I think he will try
and repress what he's seen immediately
and he will be putting pressure on local
governments I think to to control this
and and we've already had reports that
people are involved in the process have
been phoned up so their phones China has
a very effective State surveillance
communication system and they can find
out who was at these process they can
phone them and warn them so he's already
doing that but if he takes it too far
then there is the danger of further the
unrest so you know it's it's a difficult
position we've got much support to come
on this we're going to take a brief
break now when we come back we're going
to be addressing that very question now
could these protests threaten Xi Jinping
himself and his hold on power join us
for more after the break
[Music]
quite a few weeks ago operators started
to talk to me and say well you know
we're really busy coming up to Christmas
but the escalating cost electricity
bills
um oil in the fat for at the moment more
expensive than unleaded petrol so it
looks busy but actually our profits are
really really low we've not had the last
Christmas or the Christmas before that
because the pandemic and come January
people are saying we're going to have to
shut and I was thinking well you know
what can we do here in Greater
Manchester what kind of intervention is
there I came up with the idea and I
presented it to the to the gaffer Andy
Burnham who backed it straight away and
I was like look here in Greater
Manchester let's create something called
give the gift to going out so your local
family room restaurant your local family
are on Pub your local theater your local
gig venue why not create an experience
so why not get a voucher or make a book
again take your uncle out for a pint or
from meal is really working the public
have got behind it and the best thing
about this is when you hand that gift
over in January you'll probably use it
and so when you hand it over at
Christmas you'll probably use it in in
January and that is the quietest period
of the earth hospitality and that's the
period where the staff get the least
hours so it's a win-win-win for
everybody across the board let's just
put us in a Christmas card or something
you know I've got a booking on January
the 13th at such and such a venue I've
made it for seven o'clock I want to take
you out for a meal and I know that the
cost of living is is coming in I get
that but you know this is Christmas and
if you can afford 10 20 quid or whatever
so towards that give support your local
Hospitality venue because you know if we
don't do that once they're gone our high
streets are going to look completely
different and we need to do our bit this
is the big the fifth biggest sector in
the UK and I I personally think those
those bigger chains that have the banks
and the shells behind they'll always be
here but it's those smaller family-run
Independence that we we really need to
protect and and this is making a
difference in Greater Manchester
[Music]
Sky News snow report sponsored by snow
rental.co.uk
[Music]
online ski hire in Europe
Tuesday will bring more snow to Central
parts of the outs topping up levels it
looks going to be a bit dry from
Wednesday it'll stay cold so what snow
there will linger but snow depths are
limited a number of Austrian resorts are
open but runs are generally fairly short
France has more limited skin but Val
desert will open this weekend Italy has
some snow at all levels Switzerland has
recorded over a meter of snow on some
higher runs
Sky News snow report sponsored by snow
rental.co.uk online ski hire in Europe
right well after the skiing let's get
back to some serious stuff uh Sky News
where we've been answering your
questions about the unrest in China
let's uh continue with it as you know
they've been uh widespread protests
caused by the the covert lockdowns and
in particularly
a fire that took place in a block of
flats and people believe
how did it spread across China what did
what had happened in one small part of
China and why do people think covered
lockdown was to blame so a fire erupted
in last Thursday on 24th I think
um and because of the lockdown the
building was in the barricades and
things so people couldn't get out easily
and some got trapped well there were
allegations weren't there that the fire
doors were locked yeah so it took a long
time for them to come and anyway so also
people couldn't get out easily so people
blame the lockdown measures so the the
local officials denied this report and
worse still they they blame the victim
so these people they were too slow they
are not reacting quickly enough or the
ability to self-saving was very weak
this is ridiculous that caused such
outrage you know in China
um you know that there's still platform
of social media so they're spread out so
um caused anger so then we saw Saturday
people went to a street called wurumuchi
they paid the tube being laid down the
flowers and vanting anger and
frustration which has building and then
spread to other cities well we've been
talking then about the potential of
these protests the response perhaps from
the authorities we've seen some of it
already we're asking whether that
Crackdown could become more intense and
indeed where the protests might lead in
terms of particularly XI jinping's grip
on power let me put this question to you
Francis fukuyama from Lenny says is
there actually any real chance that this
leads to Xi Jinping being removed from
Power
well look it's very difficult to
speculate on this it's extraordinarily
hard to uh go after a figure that's that
dominant uh there's a you know what's
called by social scientists the
collective action uh problem because a
lot of people don't like zero covet they
don't like Xi Jinping they want
something different but coordinating
protests in a way that would actually
put pressure serious pressure on the
government is something that has been
very difficult Miss John was right in
saying that there have been many
protests over the last couple of decades
but they're all isolated but this is
different because it's happening in
multiple cities at a very large scale
it's really hard to see how the
government uses violence against every
single one of these protesters and you
know what it may mean is that for the
first time somebody in the standing
committee of the politburo says look
this is crazy you know our whole the
control of the Communist party is being
threatened by this and we've got to do
something and you know it's that point
where you might get a crack in uh you
know the the the
dominance of this one one man over uh
over the entire Communist party but you
know who knows uh uh it's a very uh
non-transparent system and we really
don't know what uh what is going on on
the inside and evolving and volatile
situation Dominic take on that question
as well as the next one which follows on
from it from Thomas he says who's set to
replace Xi Jinping in the event he's
removed well first of all is this
maybe the uh the spark that uh lights
the fuse that does seem removed I don't
think we ever see a sort of Chinese
spring um and I think for various
reasons uh most importantly shiji Bing
has and it's important to stress he's
really entrenched himself in a position
of a sort of unassailable authority in
the past a Chinese president would rule
for two terms and it was a rather
effective way of sort of keeping
continuity but evolving and learning
from the mistakes of the previous
president he's now entrenched himself in
a position the last Congress where he's
now running for he now has a third term
and Will Go On indefinitely so he's sort
of back to where Mao was a kind of
communist Emperor and he's sort of he is
renewing that kind of Imperial sense of
Chinese leadership
um so it he's in a position which would
be very hard to topple him from but I
think what it does do is undermine
fatally this idea that he's infallible
and he has cultivated this idea that he
is this sort of infallible leader that
and the Chinese Diplomatic Corps around
that and the elites have made a big
thing of this you know it's saying that
China is hugely grateful and very lucky
to have a leader of this fallibility and
I've been really frustrated with the
West saying you keep banging on about
human rights you should be celebrating
as we are this amazing man leading us to
a a new golden age of of Chinese sort of
Supremacy this this is massively
undermined that because it has obviously
punctured that myth it is exposed this
covered zero cover policy has been
completely flawed and for the first time
we're seeing the people out on the
streets demanding reform and change but
also in a few isolated cases demanding
the government to stand up okay that is
the question that maybe the last one
we've got time to address but it's
hugely important it's from Stamford who
articulates it this way what would be a
successful outcome from these protests
Legion would it just simply be a
relaxation of the zero covered policy or
something beyond that I think um Xi
Jinping were being a position to relax
the policy without feeling losing face
because he can just say look we've done
we claim the kick and declare Victory
look at China how many people died very
very the percentage is really really low
compared to America for example I think
I can it can certainly do that okay and
uh Francisco I'm your view on that what
would be a successful outcome from these
protests so relaxation in the policy and
hopefully no
violent Crackdown on the protesters
well I suppose that would be the case I
think the question is whether this
really does undermine that narrative
that was referred to you know that's
kept Xi Jinping at the center of Chinese
politics up to this point and then in
the longer term you know there could be
some shifts in the leadership that would
you know lead to a more liberal China
that would be the hope that you know who
knows whether that's remotely possible
just give me your take though uh just
very quickly if you could on that sense
that it is a crack in the sheen of
invincibility around Xi Jinping
well um
I think that
you've got to relate it to things that
are going on in the broader world uh
we've seen a remarkable uh uprising of
people all over the place I mean
ukrainians are beating the Russian
military after the invasion of Ukraine
uh people in Iran uh you know almost
eight weeks after the uh they started
are still protesting despite a fierce
Crackdown you know you've had
setbacks to populists you know
particularly in my country in the United
States I mean there's a lot of stuff
going on around the world that to me
indicates that people actually value
their freedom they don't like
authoritarian government they don't like
uh you know populists uh uh you know
that that want to tell them what to do
and it's possible that you know there's
been a shift in some way from a global
climate
excellent stuff